could it be that your success or failure
on YouTube is determined before you even
upload a video imagine if you do not
analyze the competitors put all this
energy and effort and time into your
channel only to realize that you're
fighting an unwinnable battle what's
happening in the larger market is your
overall segment meaning your topic your
Niche is it growing is it shrinking what
are the trends that are happening in it
right now
I discovered a YouTube Secret in a book
that's over 2 000 years old that changed
my life forever and this actually
reveals a mistake that 99 of YouTube
creators are making that leads to
failure the mistake is a lack of market
research let me explain in the famous
book The Art of War by military General
and strategist Sun Tzu he says this
every battle is won before it's even
fought think about that could it be that
your success or failure on YouTube is
determined before you even upload a
video could it be that whether your
business or side hustle succeeds or
fails is determined before you even
start the business and a majority of
cases the answer is yes because most
people fail to prepare in advance they
don't have an adequate preparation of
resources an adequate analysis of the
competitive landscape and ultimately
they fail at the point of market
research and so in this episode of the
think media podcast I want to share with
you a few insights from this powerful
quote from this powerful book now we
actually are in this military strategy
applied to YouTube series this is part
four and so I highly recommend checking
out the show notes to see the previous
Parts but in this episode I want to talk
about this quote every battle is won
before it's even fought what this quote
means to me is that smart strategists
ask smart questions before they enter
the battle for example what is the
number and strength of the enemy forces
and YouTube that would be considering
okay with the niche I want to go into
the topic I want to go into how many
other channels are talking about this
topic how much time have you spent
researching other people that are
directly talking about what you're
talking about maybe an adjacent niches
I've found
99.9 of creators have done almost zero
competitor analysis and I can hear the
objections oh comparison is the thief of
Joy I'm not saying compare yourself and
get discouraged I'm saying as a smart
strategist go look at what other options
there are out there consider the
strength of the enemy's forces because
the key that you're looking for is your
Unique Edge your unique difference and
there's always an opportunity for the
smart strategists you can always find an
angle to be a little bit different but
think about it imagine if you do not
analyze the competitors put all this
energy and effort and time into your
channel only to realize that you're
fighting an unwinnable battle so you
want to ask what are the strengths and
weaknesses of my potential competitors
but you also want to ask what are my
strengths and weaknesses how much time
do you have right now how much money do
you have right now what kind of
experiences in your life do you have
what kind of lessons have you learned
there's always advantages it's not about
your resources it's about out your
resourcefulness but you don't want to
get discouraged about something you
can't change you want to look at the
resources you do have what are the
relationships what are the different
opportunities that you have where what
about your location where you live and
it's not helpful for you to tell me all
the reasons it can't work oh I live in a
small town I don't have much money I
don't have any connections I got no
access to anything well cool you've
analyzed your weaknesses let's also
analyze your strengths maybe you've
researched a particular topic for years
and years and you actually could talk
for hours about it and there's a market
that wants to see content on YouTube
sharing about that topic maybe you have
a background in a particular subject
matter maybe you have a certain type of
spouse or a brother who's got a cool
garage full of stuff that would make a
great YouTube channel it's really about
auditing your potential competitors
auditing your own strengths and
weaknesses and then developing a
strategy accordingly every battle is one
1 before it's ever fought and here's
another quote from military strategist
Sun TSU from The Art of War if you know
the enemy and you know yourself you need
not fear the result of a hundred battles
if you know yourself but not the enemy
for every Victory gained you will suffer
a defeat if you know neither the enemy
nor yourself you will succumb to every
battle summary if you run into content
creation guns pleasing you'll probably
lose every time if you understand the
enemy but not yourself you'll win
sometimes and lose sometimes but if you
understand both that's going to help you
carve out your competitive advantage and
you need not fear the result of a
hundred battles but I think we can take
this quote deeper every battle is one
before it's ever fought what if we asked
how can we take advantage of the terrain
and the weather should we attack head on
or should we flank should we retreat
regroup rethink and redeploy our forces
in a better way again the novice is just
going to run into the battle not
concerned with all of these other
variables whereas the military
strategist is going to be thinking okay
I can see from the weather report in
2023 because we have this information
that uh it's gonna rain and there's
gonna be a storm maybe we should wait a
day I could see that based on the
terrain maybe head-on is not best what
if we go to this elevated position what
if we work around back through those
trees there's all kinds of Dynamics how
do you apply that to YouTube what's
happening in the larger market is your
overall segment meaning your topic your
Niche is it growing is it shrinking what
are the trends that are happening in it
right now what have been some of the
opportunities and doors that have been
opened what are maybe some of the doors
that have been closed again should you
attack head on or flank and if your
research reveals that ultimately you
you're facing an adversary that you do
not think you can overcome that doesn't
mean you should give up it just maybe
means you should Retreat regroup rethink
and then potentially redeploy your
forces in a better way a different way
how could you maybe reposition your
YouTube channel all of this is thinking
at a higher level of strategy more
questions we could ask is do I need to
get stronger do I need new gear there
could be a situation in a military
environment where literally our
technology and our gear is insufficient
and I know we always talk about it all
you need is your smartphone and
absolutely you can get started with your
smartphone but there's something about
taking a step back regrouping rethinking
and thinking okay maybe I need to level
up my strength I'm going to invest in a
particular skill set you know as we rise
to higher levels on YouTube this isn't
just about breaking through and having
some success I know we have so many
entrepreneurs and business owners
listening to this and I think about this
question for my Evolution as the leader
now of a team at think media I'm
thinking about do I need to get strong
longer yes do I need new skills
absolutely I've invested more this year
in my skills and in my learning than
ever before being a part of groups and
masterminds where I can be iron sharpens
iron with other entrepreneurs and
leaders I am doubling down in my study
of YouTube as I read articles and Google
news and I pay for my Business Insider
subscription to have more premium
content about the industry and the
Creator economy myself and the think
media team attend industry events we
need to get stronger are we investing in
New Gear we are we are trying to improve
the production quality of this podcast
and I know there's a tension because a
lot of people listen to this and I want
to encourage you start with what you
have and start on a budget that's
exactly how I started and many others
who are starting right now are having
success just using the resources they
have but you can't just stay complacent
or stay settled there's something about
looking ahead and thinking about what
skills do I need how can I level up my
gear my learning and my strategy I've
won a lot of previous battles but I need
to be preparing for my future battles
and every battle is won before it's ever
fought how can I increase the chances of
victory in my business and on YouTube
next year and the battles that I'm gonna
face it's by preparing for those battles
today and so could it be that your
success on YouTube will be determined by
your prior Planning by your next level
of thinking and by your next level of
strategy and let me just share a
disclaimer because you might say Sean
this doesn't even make sense you're the
guy who just says like start messy and
just press record and start before
you're ready well yeah because also your
life is not on the line at the same
level it is in a military strategy I
mean Sun Tzu was facing some challenges
a little bit higher than we are from
making videos at home in our bedrooms on
our iPhones and our smartphones but the
truth is that starting is part of
strategy that is you getting moving it's
you getting some experience you getting
some skill but you can't stay there so
both are true so often we're looking for
black and white answers when a lot of
truths when it comes to YouTube and
business are tensions to be managed and
the tension is start messy but that's in
tension with skill up be more strategic
have more planning and the Creator who
plans things out for example who is your
channel for does your channel have a
clear topic does your channel have a
passionate audience and what problem
does your channel solve the quality of
your answers to those questions will
determine the future success of your
YouTube channel the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins and the
Creator who sits down and makes a plan
will be the Creator who experiences
every battle being won before it's even
fought now if you want some more
resources on this topic I have a list of
things that I think will be helpful for
you first I hope you've been enjoying
this military strategy series there's
actually multiple videos in the series
we'll link these up in the show notes
not only some of the quotes from on war
from The Art of War but also the book
positioning and marketing Warfare as you
can see here at the think media podcast
we're not just trying to bring you fluff
and basic information we're trying to
really help you think at an entirely
different level of strategy you know
those who ultimately win not just on
YouTube but in business overall are
those who outwork out learn out
strategize and Outlast the competition
those are four very hard things to do
but that's why I want you to know that I
appreciate your support and you being a
part of this community so definitely
subscribe because we have future
episodes coming in this series and check
out the past episodes as well and also
if you want some help putting together
that next level of strategy you're gonna
love the free class that we have at
thinkmasterclass.com it's on demand so
you can watch it as soon as you're done
with this episode I encourage you to sit
in a coffee shop or your main computer
where you can really sit down grab a
journal and take notes because this is
real strategy we're going to roll up our
sleeves and really help you learn the
one strategy we use at think media
that's generating over 350 000 views per
day and how to monetize those views in
multiple different ways creating passive
income and so you can check that out on
demand at thinkmasterclass.com or
there's a link in the description down
below but finally if you enjoy this
content I would love it if you liked
rated and reviewed this think media
podcast wherever you watch or listen if
you're in a place where you can comment
the question of the day is what is your
aha moment from either this episode or
the other episodes I wasn't really sure
how this military strategy series would
go but I know for me quotes like every
battle is one before it's ever fought
has actually changed my life it's caused
me to think different dream different
plan different and May make different
decisions and consequently different
actions in my entire career on YouTube
video selection in my business and all
of the above and so it's been very
helpful to me so I'm just curious how's
it resonating with you does it lead to
any questions is there any topics that
you'd love to see on the think media
podcast if you're in a place to comment
I read all the comments so I'd love to
get your feedback and hear any aha
moments that you have sending you love
and respect today I appreciate you being
a part of this episode and I can't wait
to connect with you in the next one